[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
alors
le concert était incroyable parce que
jean mi non non non je dirai juste
permanent plus la pauvre obama on voit
qu'elle est en voie que c'est vrai les
muscles et c'est une artiste et femmes
ça a déjà dû lui arriver mais
effectivement alors du coup vous qu'est
ce qu'il ya merde mais ça me rappelle
une anecdote vertus deckers s'exaucer
ramassés dans les logements où
il s'était très vite fait mon entorse
mais c'est peut-être pour ça mais c'est
pas besoin de muscler keng
et donc ça nous a donné une bonne j'ai
pas de
nom mais si c'est quand tu fais la télé
tu pense toujours que tu atterris tout
le monde s'aime c'est tout des gens un
peu connu par 2,2 litres a fait quand
même des zéniths bercy dans le monde
entier et je paie long mais rarement
aussi en fait dans l'esprit de service
de l'immeuble devait
cesser ma soeur
j'ai fait la même chute et 2 millions
d'auditeurs nous avons deux millions
d'auditeurs à sera-t-elle oui bon c'est
monsieur je me lançais rgl six mois ça
va alors forcément comme on est un peu
méchant ça nous a donné une petite idée
c'est servoir voilà quelques vidéos de
la chute ça ça me fait tellement rire un
peu en sirène elle ans irène c'était
dans l'émission x factor s établit en
sirène
et sa chaise s'est cassé la gueule c'est
quand même qui est hyper y est c'est
grotesque regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors pardon et hellenic american idol
et chaque année une bonne spécialiste
n'est elle pas venue en sirène comme ça
parce qu'elle s'est dit tiens voilà
[Musique]
et sort un bouquin c'est pas possible
comme wendel est les meilleurs hamm et
meilleure alors l'habitude parce qu'elle
était aussi tombée sur une scène en
glissant sur ducasse hâte de gâteaux
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hommage
insulté lors d'une remise de prix que
trader dans la chute c'est quand tu
perds toute dignité quoi tu t'es tu as
dû te ramasses elle réagit guère parce
qu'elle est mort dorée à l'abattement de
l'est de deir ezzor et la plainte qui
tombe qui après son hyper réveiller et
ça ça change tout c'est comme quand tu
fais un petit tabac tes trucs à
l'hôpital quand c'est pas grave mais un
petit test de n'importe quoi photoshop
est une petite tu saignes espèce de
petit blues est un bon ferme derrière
des petites fesses à l'air est tout
blanc c'est grotesque attendent avec un
petit numéro il a marqué tournon comme
un chien dans un voilà et là ça va c'est
bien tpm plus souvent souvent cette
saison tu sais rue jean van hamme ça va
ça va ça va tu es dans un couloir ya pas
de place tout le cul un peu à l'air là
bas c'est bientôt à vous bah c'est
gentil on viendra demain merci beaucoup
voilà ça sent le vécu ça justin bieber
fait une chute et en concert voilà un
groupe de gospel chanter sur scène ils
devaient descendre en ange tombé du ciel
baala il est tombé
[Applaudissements]
ouais il mauvais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu violent oui alors on
modifie t pendant leur est fait mais pas
que oui que jegham les spécialistes en
régie tout ça il devait pas tomber de
seawind donc l'été prex était prévu que
cette chute métro mais je suis d'accord
là ça ressemble un peu à l'organisation
de tpm plus en prime due cette entame
une grue les nerfs de tous tu vois
effectivement battu wacken dans ses yeux
quand il se relève dit les gars oui on a
poussé un peu sur la ban oui mais voilà
lorsque j'ai deux jambes cassées c'était
drôle mais
voilà alors oui dans l'oreillette qui
nice aurait pu coûter très cher en
assurance absolument et bouchoux il est
fan total de justin bieber moi aussi là
on part maintenant sur du français c'est
bon pour se faire plaisir au dernier ces
deux là bien sûr charest shy'm sign ça
c'est quand même génial on l'a tous fait
dans une boîte de nuit un code pin quand
tout est un booking ce qu'on a pu nous
en boîte de nuit et tu te jettes dans le
public mais il n'y a pas de public gens
ne baissera pas dans une boîte de nuit
tu seras au zénith et voilà ça c'est sûr
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais bien
plus on a le sentiment que c'est un peu
comme si des avec la fin de mai elle a
fait une énorme erreur normalement quand
on se jette que je le fais souvent dans
des mariages - je vous préviens les gens
que j'arrive j'ai attention les gages
arrivés là je saute et on attrape non
mais c'est pas grave at il compris non
toi dans ton mariage qui te casse mais
dans le mariage des autres tutu et ben
ouais moi je les croisais alors j'adore
alors autant que journaliste j'aimerais
quand même vous dire un mot sur shy'm
exactement 3 et peu de temps après dans
un restaurant mais parle avec elle et
s'est jeté sur le baril
elle s'est fait mal et surtout elle a eu
très très peur parce que la tête a
failli taper trait aux lois et donc on
rit on rit maintenant on rit parce qu'il
s'est rien passé bien sûr évidemment
mais évidemment elle voyait pas parce
qu'elle avait les projecteurs de figure
est vrai que le public était devant
l'estrade sausheim et un cordon de
sécurité que des barrières du coup l
artiste sauter dans une faute avait pas
de public elle a cru que le public ait
pas de public donc elle est tombée comme
une alliance comprend une piscine vide
tout seul vous ça vous dit rien mais
tous ceux qui par don mais qui comme moi
on a fait de la scène ou qui sont à huy
une
oui les artistes sont manquantes ernst
onstage comme les américains étaient
grises et un peu et l'adrénaline est
pris par la foule parles tu entends ton
nom scandé y atteignent décharge
d'adrénaline et d'amour et et tu sautes
vers les gens qui donnent tout et dort
bien sûr il est beau
tout ça fait des eaux au macumba de metz
il ya deux semaines j'ai touché 400
euros et la dernière évidemment je n'ai
rien j'embrasse très fort je déjeune
bientôt avec elle mais cette cité lé lé
mythe iac voter dans ses pmp évident
avec cyril capucines à naves je peux pas
ne pas la passe est
vraiment où le ratio n'est jamais de la
vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas possible on
[Applaudissements]
attend aux coupures à prendre la parole
j'ai parlé avec capucine bijoux rappelé
à
jallais rap est une bonne nouvelle soit
avec capucine à se marier prochainement
voilà je ne sais pas absolument sûr
chaque info du cloud pas sur ça te coûte
par une info bah voilà ça s'appelle
dessus ça mais c'est vrai qu'il est très
très bon et ben bien suggère 2010 bah ça
me fait plaisir est très jolie caissière
en tout cas oui et puis elle tient bien
quand elle tombe avait absolument et
puis elle est maintenant à les poser
dans sa vie c'est qu'elle est amoureuse
quelqu'un qui n'est pas connu germain
meba va là bas c'est quand même génial
elle amoureuse elle est heureuse
voilà je fais du théâtre il ya un truc
que j'adore cette fille c'est tout ce
qu'elle voulait faire la fête et
solitaire son lutteur fera jamais tu as
fait la télé réalité le seul truc où ça
bloque on en parle à tout à l'heure et
benoît dubois c'est danse avec les stars
elle a rêvé de le faire benoît dubois
aussi à tf1 on leur a toujours dit vous
avez une étiquette de télé réalité qu'on
a on vous aime pas alors que quelque
part ceux qui les ont formés c'est un
autre débat
une chroniqueuse qui est à mes côtés à
la fois qu'ils pensent qu'il doit se
marier dans pas longtemps qu'ils savent
c'est caroline ithurbide taurine mardon
passé ce week end of the starry sky and
the marriage canal en cause par l'ac
marina de van au lalano train de marcher
dans la laisser là je réponds que je
pose il était marié elle était mariée
oui mais elle se remarie avec edgardo
boris elle était mariée super ont été
très forts karoui chebbi